hopefully you know get a message to my
sister that well things aren't really
what they've seen there's so much
misperception and hopefully we could
clear up record and and move forward
with peaceful resolve Meaghan Marvel's
half-sister extends an olive branch to
the Duchess of Sussex in the royal
family on live TV after causing quite a
media frenzy leading up to the Royal
Wedding I'd apologize for it to my
sister absolutely your polios to your
sister
yes and and and answer Harry I didn't at
the time did you know I was really
lashing out at media Samantha Markel
seemingly wants to bury the hatchet
would make an inference Harry once and
for all so much has spun out of control
that was never intended to and you know
I think everybody was hurt not being
included or invited to the wedding but I
felt I felt as though it could have all
been nipped in the bud had everyone been
included and and we all just agreed to
move forward with positive resolve and
and the hurt feelings wouldn't have
snowball
this isn't the first time Megan's family
has gone to the media to air out family
business Megan said Thomas Marko opened
up to Piers Morgan about his strained
relationship with his daughter after
staging paparazzi pics I thought this
would be a nice way of improving my look
well obviously that all went to hell and
I feel bad about it
I apologized for it and that's all I can
do I can't do much down that but dinner
that was mistake
back in August the source told ET the
Duchess had not spoken to her father
since her wedding and was hurt that he
kept talking to the press he has said
this week that he's been cut off from
the palace he can't get in touch with
his daughter do you think there will
ever be a reconciliation I think it's
tough you know I think that she's
clearly taken a view he's bad news for
her he's trouble but my message to
Meghan is he's your dad
[Music]